[Music]  and that's how you win the race the  right way the team winner  wha you suck  I'm one of the top five PowerPoint  presenters of all time  you know hangin rap acity  there are new friends  [Music]  you have to shake it shake it shake it  attention my name is nao chris'll flow  my name is nao MC hate-mail will now be  known as DJ Tanner  [Music]  [Applause]  seasonal profits  oh that slide up that transition  [Music]  next up quarterly expenses and I just  like be a nice guy and I just like like  all the girls in there but like it's  been like six months and I swear I  haven't gotten like one like from  anybody call me a shipbuilder all I do  is make sales  that concludes my presentation  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  bounce